One of the most notable differences between the two accents is the way we pronounce the letter R.
In America, most of us pronounce the R in words like hard, card, ever, water, and dare,...
...but Brits say, "hard, card, ever, water, and dare".
This is the difference between what's called "rhotic" and "non-rhotic" speech.
The interesting thing is that the first British that came to America did pronounce their Rs...
...and it wasn't until later in Britain, around 1800,...
...that the non-rhotic speech became popular among the upper classes in the south of England...
...and eventually became the pronunciation that was taught in schools.
Of course, there are some accents in the UK like those of Ireland and Scotland, which are rhotic,...
...and there are those in America, like in Boston, "pack your car, Harvard yard" for example,...
...and in the south that are non-rhotic and don't pronounce the R.
So the interesting thing here is that...
...the Brits may have more to do with the difference in accents than the Americans do.
In other words, it's not our fault.